cannes 20 mai 2017
robin campillo co scénariste d' entre
les murs et réalisateur des revenants et
distant worlds présente en compétition
officielle
120 battements par minute une fresque
sur l'association de lutte contre le
sida act up paris
[Musique]
quand on arrive pour faire le photocall
et les journalistes sortent de la
projection
et là tout le monde s'emballe
apparemment sur twitter et après en
interview les journalistes en pleurs
malgré son sujet difficile
une absence de tête d'affiché un
réalisateur pas encore membre de l'élite
cas d'oise le film reçoit un accueil
triomphal
la presse française et internationale
sans balle tandis que le public
ovationne s'étend à prendre en a fait
quelque chose qui est le grand prix est
attribué à
quelques jours plus tard robin campillo
monte sur la deuxième marche du podium
cannois en recevant le grand prix du
jury des mains du président pedro
almodovar je suis heureux que ça a été
une aventure aussi collective pour
rappeler une histoire qui l'a été tout
autant on n'est jamais aussi intelligent
aussi beau aussi fort qu'à plusieurs
haye
la route est longue il est à cannes nat
morts
comment ce film qui aborde de front les
ravages du sida et l'action politique
menée par act up contre l'indifférence
des pouvoirs publics est il devenu le
film français de l'année
et comment ce cri du coeur at il
rencontré un tel écho à l'instar de la
vie d'adèle autres primés cannoise
centrée sur des personnages lgbt 120
battements par minute parvient dès sa
sortie à s'extraire du ghetto du cinéma
communautaire dépassant toutes les
attentes au box-office pour se permettre
de viser le million d'entrées en france
et en rêvant le film réussit totalement
quand on nous fait pas de radeaux romain
on espérait 1 400 500 mille ans au
départ quand on est pourtant 120
battements par minute pour fièrement son
triangle rose en étendard c'est un film
qui manque l'amour gay comme quelque
chose de normal on assiste au papier
mais on lamastre pas non plus mais c'est
surtout histoire d'amour avec ses
personnages homosexuels flamboyant et
ses scènes de sexe décomplexée c'est un
film qui ne fait pas de concessions
grand public souvent perçu comme frileux
à l'égard des histoires d'amour entre
homme se cache pas d'être candidat je
suis pas payé
moi j'aimais bien en fait l'idée de
faire un un mec hyper parce que
dernièrement en fait envoyé en fait
qu'on parlait beaucoup de mots sexualité
dans les films mais il fallait avoir
l'air d'être strike d'être hétéro
pourquoi et pour moi c'est les
politiques aussi tu vas tu as décidé de
te faire là tapi au total c'est génial
quoi qu'est ce que tu veux ça va mal et
se trouvaient les i
mais je sais pas c'est quoi ton été
pas moins d'un avis si c'est repos c'est
tout voilà que ça se résume le cinéma
découvre aussi qu'il ya des choses à
raconter sur les minorités la famille
traditionnelle
un peu dysfonctionnelle hétérosexuels à
la chabrol 5arras plus personne qu'est
ce qui différencie la proche de robin
campillo la présentation d'une
communauté gay forte qui prend son
destin en main à des années lumière de
l'image de victimes présentées par la
plupart des films sur le sida depuis
philadelphia on n'a pas fait un film et
du corps et pourront plaire vraiment il
ya une comprend bien tout ce qu'on a
fait je sentais qu'on faisait un film
complètement libre je pense que ça aussi
ça joue beaucoup pour le film parce que
c'est pas forcément les zélés sortie de
placard les éternels gay con qu'on met
au ban de la société là c'est des gens
qui en veulent qui se bagarrent pour
leur droiture bien raison et qui se
modère aussi pour les droits des autres
[Musique]
c'est l'adn d'acteurs qu'ils ont refusé
de d'éviction des victimes du pouvoir
public des victimes du sida ils ont
voulu prendre les choses en main donc en
fait c'est à l'image je pense du
mouvement que le chine dépend
de prévention sur le sida parce que
l'état français est incapable et c'est
précisément grâce à ce portrait exaltant
d'un collectif qui se bat contre
l'injustice que le film a réussi à
transformer un récit historique en cri
de ralliement contemporain
c'est un film d'époque ça se passe dans
un temps présent quand on fait le film
et quand on voit le film en oublie que
c'est un signe c'est une histoire qui
s'est déroulée aux années 90 il ya plein
de petits détails comme ça on voit ils
se sont ils ont pas joué la carte de la
synchro et je pense que c'est une force
du film on le voit par exemple dans les
tatouages des acteurs c'est du tatouage
moderne à la manière de s'habiller
serait du tout la même
le stress que physique des gens parce
que le loup des gens l'écoutent les
choses comme ça du coup ça fait une
espèce d'objet qui capable temporalité
je crois que ça fonctionne encore
aujourd'hui parce que ça parle
d'engagement ça montre votantes les gens
s'unissent pour une cause juste
il arrive à quelque chose ça c'est un
message qu'on a largement besoin
d'entendre aujourd'hui dans tous les
domaines
[Musique]
c'est un fils de niche
on n'a jamais en tout cas perçu comme ça
on a perçu comme un film qui vraiment
été pouvait parler à beaucoup de gens
qui ont une âme militante qu'on va lire
et même des les avant-premières c'était
pas un public forcément gay qui venait
qui venaient voir quoi et on applique et
très féminin on est à 70 % féminin pas
les deux stats et 70 % du public en sus
de femmes on s'aperçoit qu'on a un film
qui est très jeune qui plaît ça c'est
vraiment la première réussie la première
faire des grenats on est vraiment en
public qui est assez jeune
une jeunesse qui re découvre depuis peu
l'engagement politique et peut
reconnaître dans la lune d'act up
les coûts de ses propres combats on
reçoit beaucoup de messages sur les
réseaux sociaux
deux jeunes garçons de jeune fille qui
découvre un truc qui sert à mais comment
je peux faire maintenant pour m'investir
pour la prévention pour la politique
pour 6 pour ça au gré du bouche à
oreille
le film voit triplé son nombre de salles
destiné au départ aux salles d'art et
essai 120 battements par minute aura
finalement conquis les multiplexes
je pense que ce qui m'est arrivé un
moment où les gens beaucoup de gens ont
envie de
de rompre un fatalisme comme ça où les
choses ne peuvent pas se faire et vous
voyez on peut faire des choses
positivement ensemble une histoire de
timing peut-être que c'était le moment
pour ce film là un film en phase avec
son époque qui a été choisi pour
représenter la france à l'oscar du
meilleur film en langue étrangère
l'an prochain donc il ya quelque chose
de vague de chêne quotas qui se donc
vous dire quand ça va s'arrêter
c'est assez surprenant ouais bah moi je
suis très méfiant de tout ce qui est
mainstream notamment jeu je me dis est
ce que c'est bien je pense à tout donner
dans ce but qui va jusqu'à dire pour le
système tu acceptes autant tu dis est ce
qu'on a fait quelque chose qui n'est pas
exactement ce qu'on aurait dû faire
et non ça c'est juste mon peuple est
parano qui les l'oscar le césar convient
souhaite aussi août quelque prix que ce
soit ça changera pas l'engagement des
gens les engagements des gens c'est ce
qu'ils vont voir le film qui vont
s'engager après ça le film l'a déjà
gagnée
[Musique]